les écuries royales de versailles
vitrine du savoir faire à la française
prochainement 6000 mètres carrés seront
entièrement dédiés aux filières
d'excellence les métiers de paysages
d'art ou encore du patrimoine bâti
seront notamment représentés du fait du
drame que nous avons vécu en début de
semaine ces métiers d'art sont
particulièrement à regarder parce que
nous devons former des jeunes à ces
métiers que sont les métiers d'art les
métiers de la construction
tous les métiers qui vont être impliqués
dans la reconstruction de notre dame de
paris
pas de création d'établissements pour ce
projet l'idée est de réunir sur un même
lieu des institutions déjà existantes
pour donner la possibilité aux étudiants
de mieux se former dans un domaine c'est
pas un gadget atteint on vient là parce
que dans son cursus
on doit faire un chef-d'oeuvre on doit
faire un projet et on vient de semaine
avec les enseignants travailler sur un
projet ou peut-être un peu plus ou un
peu moins
l'objectif est également de susciter des
vocations pour ces filières en recherche
de compétences la possibilité de
travailler en relation étroite avec les
filières professionnelles du secondaire
autour de tous les métiers du château ça
permet à mon établissement en fait
d'élargir le champ et le spectre de ses
activités ça me permet aussi d'être en
prise en prise directe sur des lycéens
qui vont pouvoir ensuite intégrer
éventuellement l'école nationale
supérieure des arts décoratifs des
hébergements des infrastructures
culturelles et sportives compléteront le
dispositif pour l'heure aucune date n'a
été avancée pour l'ouverture de ce
campus pas de chiffres non plus
concernant le financement de ce projet